I was exposed to this financial market
short-term pressure on a daily base now
we resist it for example we still don't
give quarterly profit figures and we
have been called dinosaurs and and and
and secret and I don't know what and and
certainly have been punished sometimes
by the financial markets we're not doing
so but it was done on the absolute
conviction that if you give in and just
starts to give quarterly profit figures
the organization will start to sink in
quarterly terms because each of the
figures that you present afterwards is
going to be interpreted is going to be
extrapolated is going to be discussed
and the whole organization is going to
sink for at least a period of two months
nothing but the quarterly figures and I
don't think that's good for business I
don't think it's good for the long-term
value creation for our shareholders so
therefore we resisted and we went too
far that we don't go to any stock
exchange where quarterly reporting is
being demanded so we stay at home now
you have to be convinced of this and by
doing so and at the same time by
performing you will then start to
convince shareholders that this is
perhaps a different way but a very good
way for them and today we have from more
than fifty percent of our shareholders
we are being encouraged not to go to
quarterly profit and I think this is the
result of consistency coherency over
many many years so it can be done I know
it's not easy but I think it is good for
the shareholders in the long term
think sometimes they have been
forgetting what the real roles in
society should be I mean the real roles
in society was to be the oil of the real
economy the real role in society was how
and were do you really put money in
order to foster certain industries or
how to assure long-term development the
man if I think back for example here in
Switzerland the role of the banks in
order to create the infrastructure to
build the first railway tunnels through
the Alps and things like this those who
are pioneering works which today have
been a little bit downplayed i would say
in the financial words and it comes
rather back to proprietary proprietary
trading where it comes more to the
speculative aspect of the hedging aspect
and things like this as value crater so
I think the financial world should and
hopefully will also look a little bit
into into their own role in society and
perhaps amend some of the things that
have happened but where I agree with you
what is sometimes more disturbing is
that they try to impose very very i
would say simple-minded monetary vision
on the ce o--'s or on the management of
the real economy and it comes back to
the quality of the CEOs